now this year's nominees for Best  Performance by an actress in a  supporting role Kathy Bates  and about Schmidt  Julianne Moore and the hours  Queen Latifah in Chicago  Meryl Streep in adaptation  Catherine zeta-jones and Chicago  and the Oscar goes to Catherine  and  this is Catherine zeta-jones first  Academy Award and her first nomination  thank you so much my scotsman giving the  Welsh girl I can't believe it oh my gosh  this is too I mean my hormones are just  too way out of control for me to be  dealing with this but thank you so much  the Academy and to be nominated with  such amazing women in a amazing year for  women thank you very much everyone  involved in Chicago there's so many  people Rob Marshall Harvey Weinstein  Craig Neal everybody and all the cast  and crew everybody in Swansea South  Wales I love you and to my son Dylan  who is gonna be watching at home and to  my husband who I love and I share this  award with you along with this one -  thank you so much